翻訳: Nana Machidori
校正: Maki Sugimoto
これは私が30年前
まだ若かった頃の写真です
ちょうど 会場にいる２番目の娘と
同い年のときの写真です
それから大学を卒業し
小児科の道に入り
患者さんと対峙しながら
研究をして
２人の子どもの母親として
育児を頑張ってきました
子どもの発達に関わる
仕事をしてきました
愛着は子どもの発達に
とっても大事なんです
愛着には３つの方法があります
目と目で見つめ合う
手と手で触れ合う
そして 微笑むことです
親から たっぷりの愛情を
子どもはもらうことで
安定した愛着が定着し
親が子どもにとって
安全基地になるんです
しかし この赤ちゃんをご覧ください
こういう風にお祖母ちゃんから
日常的に怒鳴られ
ガミガミ言われると
安定した愛着が作られずに
不安定な愛着
発達が止まってしまい
視線も合わなくなります
その赤ちゃんが
お祖母ちゃんから引き離すことで
こんなにかわいい笑顔の
赤ちゃんに戻りました
発達も戻ったんですよ
びっくりポンですよね
（笑）
虐待やネグレクトのような
不適切な養育が
愛着障害を引き起こすことが
分かってきました
例えば 家庭で親が
いろんな
虐待に近い暴言を吐いたり
厳しい長期的な体罰を与えると
親が出かけようとしても
子どもは後追いもしません
悲しみもしません
そして戻ってきても
きょとんとして 喜びもしないんです
心の発達に問題を抱え
様々な症状を呈するんです
例えば 内向きに症状が出ますと
他人に対して無関心で 用心深い
イライラしやすくなって
いろんな人間関係に支障をきたします
また 外側に出てしまうと
多動 落ち着きがない
そして友達とのトラブルが多い
喧嘩が絶えないです
人見知りもなくなって
また他人との良い関係が
作れなくなるんです
愛着障害は 実は
社会的な養護と言われる—
養護施設や児童自立支援施設のような
ところに暮らしているお子さん
それから里親に養子として
引き取られたお子さんの
40パーセントにこういった障害が
出ることが分かってきたんです
大変なことなんですよ
そして 本人のみならず
家族にも苦しみを与えます
例えば 精神の病を発症するんです
うつ病 アルコールや薬物の依存症
PTSD 統合失調症
そして様々な人格障害
こういった精神の病で
本人のみならず 家族まで苦しみます
そして 虐待の被害者は
その虐待を受けた子ども
本人だけではなくて
他人や 回り回って私達社会に
苦しみが返ってくるんです
例えば こういうお子さん達は
いじめの加害者になります
そうすると 皆さんのお子さんが
学校でいじめにあって
心の傷が残ったりします
それから こういう虐待の被害者は
生活に困窮します
社会的に適応できなかったり
そして 精神の病に陥って
生活保護費や医療費の負担が増え
結果的に経済の悪化を招くんです
児童虐待によって生じる
社会的な経費や損失は
なんと１年間だけで１兆６千億円も
多いことが分かっています
このほかに肺癌や心疾患のリスクが
生涯で３倍に増え
20年も寿命が縮まってしまうんです
もはや個人の問題だけではなく
社会全体の問題なんです
これまでの研究で
大量のストレスホルモンが
脳の発育を遅らせることが
分かってきました
小さい時期に虐待の
ストレスを受けると
それがずっと脳の
扁桃体という感情の中枢を
異常に興奮させます
それで副腎皮質に司令が行って
ストレスホルモンが
どんどん出てしまって
脳にダメージを与えるんです
実は 私は研修医になったときに
救急外来に運ばれてきた
３歳の男の子のことを
今でも忘れることができません
その子は実の両親から虐待を受けて
脳内出血で運ばれてきたんです
全身にはタバコの火を押し付けた
火傷の跡がありました
３日間 何とかその子の
命を助けようと
集中治療室で
救命に頑張ったんですが
命は助かりませんでした
無償の愛を注ぐべき親が
なぜ子どもに虐待をしてしまうのか
にわかには理解できませんでした
私はこの問題をなんとかしようと
研究を始めたんです
アメリカのボストンへの留学で
分かったことがあります
例えば 長期的に激しい
体罰を受け続けると
頭の前の方 感情の中心である—
前頭葉が小さくなります
自分をコントロールできなくなり
凶暴になって
しかも集中力も落ちるんです
そして 暴言虐待を受け続けると
なんと 聴覚野が変形して
音や聞こえ 会話 コミュニケーションに
障害が起きてしまいます
そして 親のDVを目撃することで
視覚野が小さくなると
相手の表情が分からなくなり
対人関係に支障をきたします
こういう脳の変化は外部からの
ストレスを極力避けるために
情報量を減らすための
脳の防衛本能だと考えられています
私達の研究で
健康な子どもに比べて
愛着障害を持つお子さんは
お金というご褒美に
脳が反応しないことが分かってきました
これもびっくりポンです
褒める言葉が響かないのです
自己肯定感を上げることができませんよね
実は１歳頃に虐待を受けると
ご褒美への脳活動が
最も低下することが分かってきました
いかに早い時期の虐待防止が
切実に大事かということを
物語っています
虐待のストレスを
小さい時期に受けると
大人になって 親になって
我が子に虐待や
ネグレクトを繰り返すんです
虐待は連鎖するんです
私はこのような仕事をしていると
たくさんのお手紙[を頂きます]
その中には感謝のメッセージがあります
とっても嬉しいです
私の方が感謝です
一部をご紹介します
この方のご主人は小さい頃
虐待を受けて育ちました
「世の中このような人々が
たくさんいるんじゃないかなぁ
と思っています
先生 私も自分の気持ちに
整理がつきました
60歳を過ぎてやっと
安心して生活できます」
こう書いてありました
また 自らも親から虐待を
受けて育った30代の女性
「このように一般にも広めて頂き
子どものころ被害にあって
今も苦しんでいる者として嬉しいです」
と書いてありました
では皆さん ここで考えてください
どうやったら こういう人達を
増やさないことができるでしょうか？
いい日本語がありますね
「おせっかい」です
「おせっかい」は子どもを救うのです
「おせっかい」は「貝」ですよ
（笑）
これは東京都の児童虐待防止啓発の
キャラクターです
見てください こんなにおせっかいに
活動している人がたくさんいます
本当におせっかいなんだから！
でも これくらいが
ちょうどいいんですよ
大事なのは
こういう子育て困難や
そんな子ども達に無関心に
ならないことが一番です
皆さんができることから
アクションを起こして
養育者支援の主役になるのです
そうすることで この子ども達が
幸せになることができると思います
子どもは実の親だけでなく
社会が育てていくという視点で
愛情のある言葉かけを
近くの子ども達にしてあげる
それから 子育て困難な親に
寄り添ってあげる
そういった家庭の情報を
他機関に繋いでいく
そうすることで虐待の連鎖を
断ち切ることができるかもしれません
もちろん １人のおせっかいではダメです
みんなで おせっかいを
しないといけません
現在 どうやったら養育者に
上手におせっかいを焼けるのかを
分野を超えた仲間と研究しています
学校 法律 施設
警察 研究 医療
そして地域社会と
子どもを守るという
とても大事な連携した研究に
取り組んでいます
虐待を防止する方法だけでなく
子育て困難な親に対する対策を
仲間とともに提言して
いきたいと考えています
「虐待をしなければ 子育て困難でもいい」
とは言えないからです
政府がお金を子ども達に
かける場合に
学童期やそれ以降に
お金をかけるよりも
もっと早い時期 乳児期に
お金をかける方が
より効果が高いということも
分かってきました
起こった犯罪に厳罰を与えるよりも
病気になった人を治療するよりも
もっと養育者支援に
お金をかけた方が
効果が高いんです
それだけ社会の苦しみが
減るのですよ
「あなたの笑顔に会えて良かった」
子ども達の笑顔を取り戻すために
そういった養育困難な親に対する
周囲の支援の必要性を
提言したいと思います
そのためにも 虐待に無関心にならず
皆さんができることから
アクションを起こして頂きたいです
親が子どもに虐待をする
社会のシステムを変えるのです
「命がけのゆりかご」という
報道をご紹介したいと思います
中国の四川省で８年前に
大地震が起きました
捜索隊が瓦礫の中から
必死になって探したときに
生まれたばかりの
赤ちゃんを抱くお母さんが
四つん這いになって
息絶えていたのです
その体の下で奇跡的に
赤ちゃんは生きていたんです
そして こういうメッセージが
携帯に残っていました
「もしあなたが生き延びてくれたら
私が愛していたことを忘れないで」と
このお母さんは幼子の
未来を守ったんです
これが親 本来の姿
自分の体を張ってでも
我が子の命を守ろうとする行動です
今日はこれまで分かってきた
虐待に関する脳科学研究をご紹介しました
児童虐待にどう対応するか
そういった子ども達の
ケアや支援をどう繋げていくか
そのために自分は何ができるかを
希望を持って考えてください
親が子どもを虐待する
社会のシステムを変える
それは 皆さん１人１人の
行動にかかっているんです
ご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）